Você quer que eu pegar para você ali, ó?
Posso contribuir
meus conversos e ela me deu uma missão.
Fale de RDN. Muito bem. Missão dada,
missão cumprida. Então, estou aqui para
falar para vocês uma ferramenta que eu
uso todos os dias no consultório para
várias doenças diferentes, mas hoje o
nosso enfoque vai ser sobre oncologia.
Nós vamos falar do da aplicação da
trexona para oncologia.
Bem, para quem não me conhece, essa é
minha formação. Eu tenho formação em
medicina ortomolecular, medicina
funcional integrativo, estilo de vida,
tem uma formação internacional também,
sou certify aí do Instituto
ARN.
E também tem a formação do Dr. Lemos que
tá dando aula aqui na outra aula, aqui
na outra sala.
Muito bem, não tem nenhum conflito
interesse sobre esse assunto. E ao final
dessa apresentação quero que vocês
entendam como é que funciona o mecanismo
de funcionamento para flexiona, qual é a
sua aplicabilidade clínica, os
protocolos, as evidências atuais por
tipo de câncer e reconhecer limitações e
perspectivas futuras.
A história da é uma história muito
linda, é a história do Dr. Bernard Bari,
um médico psiquiatra, tem formação em
Harvard, também tem formação em
neurologia e nos anos 80
estava tratando muitos pacientes que
tinham problemas de adicções, viciados
em drogas, especialmente heroína. E
vocês se lembram, os que têm idade para
lembrar que nos anos 80 começamos os
primeiros casos de HIV da aid do do
SIDA. Então aconteceu uma situação muito
curiosa. Dr. Bari estava tratando de
vários adictos, vários viciais heroína,
que também eram pontadores pelos casos
de áries. Ele começou a perceber que
aqueles pacientes que estavam usando uma
trexona de alta dosagem, que é
totalmente diferente da baixa dosagem,
vou explicar para vocês aqui. Esses
pacientes que estavam usandoxona de alta
dosagem, eles estavam tomando para se
livrar do vício de heroína. né? Só que
ele tava percebendo que esses pacientes
estavam tendo respostas melhores. Eles
não estavam desenvolvendo tanto a não
estavam desenvolvendo as infecções
oportunísticas. Então ele falou, alguma
coisa tem aqui. Esse negócio aqui que
deveria tá atuando só para tirar o
pessoal do vício, tá atuando no sistema
imune, melhorando as defesas do
organismo e esse pessoal tá indo melhor.
Ele é um cara brilhante, ele é um cara
extremamente empírico na prática
neuclínica e ele é muito inteligente.
começou a testar várias doses diferentes
de Trexona
e percebeu resultados excelentes e ele
intuiu que isso estava acontecendo
porque o sistema naquela época nos anos
80 ninguém sabia isso que tinham
cruzamento do sistema imune. Ele intuiu
então que a modulação do sistema imune
pela trxona estava dando esses
resultados melhores dos pacientes HIV e
também deos heroína. Então ele intuiu
que talvez o mecanismo fosse através dos
receptores opiores na membrana celular.
E ele não sabia na rua que existia o
sistema GFR. E depois vou mostrar aqui o
trabalho do Ian Zagon, que depois ele
confirmou os achatos do Dr. R mostrando
que o organismo compensa o bloqueio
temporário para trxona de baixa dosagem
bloqueia por 4 horas somente e depois
dessas 4 horas o sistema, opor de todo
do organismo melhora, aumenta setores,
aumenta a atividade das metencefalinas e
isso tem um efeito imune que eu já vou
explicar sobre isso, porque o Toprar ele
testou com várias doses diferentes e ele
chegou na dose de 1,5 a 4,5 mg por dia,
que ele viu que era a melhor dose pra
modulação Temho.
Então, eh, ele viu que o melhor horário
para diministrar era o horário noturno.
Por quê? Porque o pico das endorfinas
endógenas era entre 2 e 4 horas da
manhã. Então, você fazer um bloqueio na
hora de deitar 4 horas, 4 a 6 horas
depois todo aumentava, tanto os sepores
quanto a própria metencefalina, que são
as endorfinas endógenas.
E aí ele começou também a tratar outros
pacientes, pacientes com doenças
autoimunes, pacientes também com câncer.
E ele tem 450 casos tratados com câncer
até os anos 2000. Ele tratou do final
dos anos 80 até os anos 2000. E
descobriu sim que axção é de baixa
dosagem, sempre de baixa dosagem, nós
estamos falando aqui do LDM,
melhora a função imune, vou falar os
ventoras moleculares um pouquinho mais
adiante,
induz a morte celular programada chamada
apoptose e também tem efeito contra
angiogênes, que é a formação de vasos
aumentada que acontece no câncer.
E
ele não foi tão valorizado pelos
especialistas, pelos cientistas, porque
ele tinha uma atuação muito focada na
prática. Ele era um médico muito
prático. Então, infelizmente nesse
momento, depois de ter tratado centenas
de pacientes, ele não tinha sido ainda
visto com o devido respeito da oncologia
convencional devido à falta de ensaios
clínicos anomizados durante esse caba. E
por que que falta esses estudos
atualizados de larga escala? Porque é
muito caro fazer receber, né? Randomiz
control trial é muito caro. São muitos
milhões de dólares e ninguém vai
investir milhões e milhões de dólares
para fazer um estudo que o seu vizinho
pode pegar o restaurante do estudo e
vender igual você medicamento, porque
não tem mais patente. A LDM, a trexona,
perdeu patente já há muito tempo, por
ser uma droga dos anos 80.
Muito bem. Esse os dois aqui são os
fundamentais que começaram a fazer os
estudos clínicos, os estudos em
laboratório com LDN. Então, Dr. Ianagon,
Dra. Patrícia McLufflin na Pa State
University foram os pioneiros para
estudar como funcionava molecularmente o
LDM. Então eles descobriram o fator de
crescimento
opio de OGF e descobriram o OGFR. O OGF
também conhecido como metaencefalina.
E hoje FR também é conhecido como
receptor zopiódeic, que antigamente só
se tinha o K e o delta e tinha um bu. Aí
descobriu esse CTOZA foi uma descoberta
posterior.
E aí eles entenderam que esse sistema
OGF, o GFR era um sistema muito
importante nas células de regulação do
crescimento celular e que se você tem um
aumento da expressão do GF e FRR, você
tem um aumento de quê? De bloqueio da
reprodução da célula. Então, quando eles
começaram a estudar o verificaram que
essa ação de Ormese, que que significa
isso? Bloqueou o receptor por pouco
tempo, porque a dose é baixa,
desbloqueou, todo o sistema opodou.
Quando aumentou o sistema piode,
bloqueou a replicação celular. Isso é a
base da ação telene para tratamento do
câncer. Ele tem ação citostática, não é
citopósica, ele não mata a célula
tumoral, ele impede da célula tumoral se
replicar. Mas tem outros mecanismo de
ação que eu vou falar aqui.
Então, de novo, vou repetir isso aqui
para ficar didático. Há um bloqueio 4 a
6 horas no receptor.
Quando ocorre o desbloqueio, o sistema
entende: "Opa, pera aí, ficou faltando.
Preciso produzir mais. produz mais fator
de metaencefalina, produz mais receptor,
todo o sistema fica mais ativo, o
receptor fica mais sensível e aumenta
então essa atividade do OGF. O OGF se
liga o receptor, vai lá pro núcleo da
célula, aumenta a produção do P16, do
P21, que vão pedir pra célula, opa, não
se replique, não se replique, fica
parada aí, não faça síntese material
para ter a replicação ao celular. Então
esse é o efeito citostático do LDN no
câncer.
Então o mecanismo principal que eu
acabei de falar por causa dessa parada
do círcico celular em G1S e esse
regulation que é o nome chique para
dizer que aumentou o receptor,
acontece então esse bloqueio da
replicação celular e descobriu que quase
todos os tumores humanos têm expressão
desse receptor ou GF GFR. mais de 90%
dos cânceres testados, 47 lineares
diferentes. Então, quase todos os
cânceres têm a aplicação do LDN.
Mas não é só isso. O LDN também tem uma
ação imunoestimulante direta. Ela
aumenta a atividade pH1 em relação a
pH2. Ela aumenta a atividade dos
macrófagos N1 em relação a macrófos M2.
Aumenta a atividade netroquiller, que é
uma célula que mata a célula tumoral.
aumenta também a questão da ação dos
linfócos B e inibe essas células T-Rex,
as células terriburadoras, que é o é a
turma do deixa disso, deixa disso. O se
imune precisa ter um freio, né? Então
nós temos um sistema muito sofisticado
de freio. Então LDM fala assim: freio
não entra aqui porque as células
tumorais elas enganam o nosso organismo
e fala assim: "Olha, eu não sou inimigo
não, não precisa me atacar". Aí os imune
cai na conversa dele, não ataca e o não
se desenvolve. Então o del uma das ações
dele justamente segurar a turma do deixa
disso, que é esse aqui e esse aqui,
células mieloides e tirs. Então fala
assim, sistema imune continua atacando o
câncer, tá? Isso era horrota, era
conversa fiada do câncer. Isso aí
precisa desata atacar sim. Então e
diminui o checkp imune. O que que é isso
aqui? é outro sistema que o o câncer usa
para enganar o organismo. O checkpint
assim fala assim: "Para aí de atacar, eu
sou amigo". Ele engana o sistema
imônico. E o LDN ajuda a reduzir esse
efeito de enganação do tumor e o sistema
imune fica mais eficiente.
Isso aqui é um esquema mostrando os
efeitos da LDN. Aumentando macróf M1
diminuindo M2. M2 da tubo não deixa
disso. Ah, a tuba não deixa disso. Sai
para lá. Tem que atacar o tumor. O tumor
não é amigo. Aumenta o linfócito CD4,
que é o linfócito helper. Aumenta o CD8
que ataca a célalk natural killer
e também ajuda a modular linfócito B e
célula nitrítica, que é outro tipo de
célula que mata o tumor também.
Aqui mostrando que axona de alta dosagem
tem um efeito completamente diferente da
baixa dosagem.
Autadosagem, tem hora que ele estimula o
tumor e tem hora que ele bloqueia o
tumor. Por quê? Porque a altrexona de
alta dosagem acaba pegando os outros
receptores ombióis não são o GF. E aí
tem essa essa ação paradoxal, te hora
que estimula, tem hora que inibiga.
Então a gente tem que trabalhar na faixa
de 1 a 5 mg,
porque aqui é garantido que vai ter a
modulação do sistema imune e também do
sistema TLR4, que eu já vou falar. Tá?
Logo adiante.
Isso aqui mostrando também que tem pouco
receptor antes de você usar o RDN. Aí
bloqueia o receptor, bloqueia aqui, ó, a
chave geratura, né? Bloqueia. Depois de
4 a 6 horas, imune responde aumentando
toda a atividade do sistema PIO,
aumentando número de setores e
aumentando a quantidade de OGF para
poder bloquear a replicação dessa
célula.
Muito bem. Esse aqui é outro mecanismo,
antagonismo TR4. Que que isso que é
importante? Porque essa é uma outra ação
muito interessante na frxona que eu uso
para mim. Eu tomo já há 8 anos na frxona
de baixa dosagem. Por quê? Porque ele
modula a micrógra.
Modula micrógra. Que que significa isso?
A micrógra é uma célula de defesa do
organismo, só que fica no cérebro. Ela
fica perto do neurônio e a negrógra
quando ela tá irritada
é igual a sua esposa de mau humor, ela
começa te atacar,
entendeu? Igualzinho. Então nós
precisamos modular a micrógra, é acalmar
a onça de casa.
Porque quando a micróga ela tá agitada,
ela acaba o quê? atacando leano sem
querer. É igual a esposa que te ano te
ataca sem querer.
Então eu preciso acalmar essa onça aí.
Como é que eu acalmo o LDN? É uma das
ações do LDN que tem aplicação na
neurologia e na oncologia. Por que na
oncologia? Porque o LDN ajuda a reduzir
a fadiga,
aquela questão também do sono ruim do
paciente oncológico e ajuda também a dor
neuropática.
Então ajuda muito tempo para seus
pacientes tem uma resposta positiva com
a BM
e tem efeito antiangogênico também.
Então, além de tudo isso que eu falei,
ela bloqueia a replicação dos vasos que
vão alimentar o tumor. Então, ela ajuda
a controlar também essa exposição dos
vasos sanguíneos aumentados para nutrir
o tumor.
e ajuda inclusive nesse agente aqui que
é um desses agentes chiques aí
anticorpoal caro Paraná que bloqueia
antijogênese também ele ajuda isso aqui
a funcionar melhor só que não mais
barato, né, obviamente, né?
E para que que nós vamos usar o RDM?
Pacientes oncológicos em geral e também
os refatários, tanto para controlar a
dor, para controlar a fadiga, melhorar o
sono para ajudar a combater o câncer. E
lógico, ele nunca usar LD sozinho em
paciente oncológico. A gente entra com
30 coisas diferentes juntos, sabe, né?
Esse é meio maluco, sai dando cápsula ao
ninguém agora tomar para cá, né? Mas é a
realidade da mediva. Você trabalha com
monte de artigo diferente para ter os
melhores resultados. Então a gente não
trabalha com isso isolado, mas is ajuda
muito. É mais uma ferramenta pra gente.
E tem vários centros aí. O MD Anderson
usa usa ele como tratamento preventivo
ou para controle da qualidade de vida.
Então por que usar BDN? Mais de 35 anos
de pesquisa, múltiplos mecanismos de
ação de tumoral, perfil de segurança
muito bem estabelecido, muito bem
estabelecido, baixo custo e boa
disponibilidade.
E tá crescendo a cada ano as prescrições
da LDN. Tem uma fundação lá na
Inglaterra, o LDN Research Trusts, que
faz um congresso anual todo ano, lógico,
anual todo ano.
Vamos lá.
Ele faz um congresso anual. É o único
congresso que eu conheço que é de uma
droga só. Vocês conhecem algum congresso
fala só a droga? É uma conheço. Todo ano
ele tem lá na no Caribe o congresso. E
esse pessoal lá do LDN research tem
vários médicos lá na utilizando RDN já
muitos anos para muita doença. Mas o
assunto hoje aqui é oncologia. que aqui
no Brasil é mais consumido na região
Centro-Oeste, Sul, Sudeste e existe uma
proposta legislativa para incluir esse
produto do SUS.
[Música]
Muito bem, vou falar aqui de estudos
glioblastoma,
tumores cerebral. Tem um estudo pequeno
piloto que foi usando a radioterapia com
LDM, teve 50% de sobrevivida em um ano
versus só 9% de controle. O problema é
que esse estudo foi pequeno, porém
ajudou muito a radioterapia atuar e
reduziu a ativação do problemaalta que
eu falei, aquela célula de defesa do
cérebro, né, que acaba atrapalhando o
paciente, aumentando a dor e tudo mais.
Só que teve um random mais control
drive, teve um siteomizado pela
Universidade Dilk em 2022 que eles não
viram melhora na fadiga e na qualidade
de vida. Não sei porque não deu
resultado nesse estudo, pode ser algum
viés aí, mas enfim, eu preciso mostrar
para vocês os dois lados. Eu uso há
muitos anos e eu acredito e confio em
mim mesmo, só que eu tenho que mostrar
os dois lados de estudo falando nesse
nessa população de Cleoma que não teve
resposta. Eu acho que pode ter sido
algum interesse aí comercial atuando
nesse sentido.
Muito bem.
Existe também evidências para câncer de
mama, tá? Tanto em laboratório, tumores
de que respondem ao hormônio, né, são
receptores positivos para esse progên
teve uma boa resposta, redução de 23% do
tumor, modelos, animais e clínicas. Teve
um estudo 2023 em que cinco de oito
pacientes tomando LDN tiveram
estabilização das metácesas no PETSCAN.
aquele catomografia por emissão de
Positrons, que usa o FDG como marcador
na maioria das vezes para ver se metáis.
Então, com esse tratamento com a RDM
houve regressão nas metástases, só que
foi só por sete semanas. Então, nesse
estudo houve resposta, porém nesse
estudo a resposta foi temporária, por só
sanas.
E tem esposadamento usando junto com
proprodológico. Eu vou falar isso logo
adiante. Mas o importante não tem
toxicidade nenhuma. É uma droga
extremamente segura, toxicidade grau
alto, não teve nenhum cálcio.
Para câncer de oválio também tem
robustas atividades pré-clínicas em
governo do laboratório, tá? Junto com a
sis platina que o quinoterápico ajudou a
sis platina a agir, tá? teve um efeito
superior ao parol de fimoterapia, só que
não temos estudos clínicos de muita
volta ainda.
Para câncer pancreático, a gente tem os
casos Dr. Berkson, Dr.
que estudou por vários anos casos
críticos que ele usou alfao,
naxção oral e pacientes que eram para
viver de três a 6 meses viveram até 78
meses com esse tratamento. Então isso
foi tão impactante na época que Dr.
Berkson fez isso, que o NCI, é o
National Canos Estados Unidos, teve que
aceitar os resultados dele e eles
sugeriram que fossem feitos mais
estudos. o protocolo do câncer
patriarco, porém
infelizmente até hoje não foi pra
frente. Não sei por, não me perguntou.
Muito bem. Textino grosso
teve resposta junto com floracil,
responsividade alguns casos críticos
acima 75%. Câncer de próstata birrar
matou vários casos de câncer de
próstata. Tem estabilização das
metástases, controle de lesões e
progressão mais lenta no PSA, que você
sabe que é o marcador que a gente usa
para câncer de prósto. Câncer de pulmão
também teremos resultados.
Então, já comentei isso aqui, o ano
flexiona, melhora o sono, reduz a fadiga
e tem também uma coisa que eu não falei,
benefícios cognitivos, tá? O LDN ele
ajuda na cognição e aí ele ajuda naquela
situação da mental da quimioterapia, que
é o chemograin, pessoal, vamos inglês,
chobinou
no camin,
tá?
Então, prós do LDN, múltiplas mecanis de
ação, excelente perfil de segurança,
baixo custo, alta disponibilidade.
Não que até onde eu sei, nunca vi nenhum
caso de câncer que precisou suspender o
LM, ah, isso aqui é incompatível,
testação, o paciente não pode estar
tomando morfina ou piódia, já vou falar
disso agora. Porém, por tratamento de
câncer, ele ajuda outros tratamentos,
ajuda químico, ajuda rádio, ajuda a
imunoterapia. Então é muito difícil
fazer um caso que não vai poder usar o
em conjunto com várias outras coisas,
tá? Ninguém tá falando aqui só us que a
solução definitiva para tudo, não é
isso? Tô dando mais uma ferramenta aqui
para vocês, tá?
Então existe esse esquema titulação, tá?
Você começa geralmente com 1,5 mg ao
deitar, vai subindo de semana em semana,
3, 4,5. Se o paciente for muito
sensível, começa duas mais baixas, 0,5
mg, 1 mg. E pode, em vez de subir uma
vez por semana, vem subindo a cada duas,
três semanas, isso vai ser mais comum
paciente sensível ou idosos que vai ter
menos tolerância à medicação. E você
pode usar até doses mais baixas, 0,1 mg
em alguns casos, tá? depende da
sensibilidade do paciente.
Então, o horário ideal é uma hora antes
de dormir
por causa daquele pico das endorfinas
que eu já comentei com vocês, porque
você vai tomar se lá 10 horas da noite,
4 horas depois vai dar o pico de
endorfina, que é o melhor horário, onde
tem mais produção defina natural. Porém,
eu tenho vários pacientes que tomam de
manhã, tá? Não é proibido usar de manhã.
Eh, tem gente que não se dá bem, tem
insônia, tem pesadelo, já vou falar
disso agora. Então você pode mudar o
horário ou mais cedo, tipo meia da
tarde, ou você pode passar de manhã, se
a pessoa forível.
E idealmente você vai usar cápsulas ou
comprimidos
manipulado, porque você não vai obter
nessa dosagem na farmácia comum. Na
farmácia comum chama-se révia, é de 50
mg, não tem nada a ver com isso aqui. É
uma dose alta para pessoas que têm
vício, né, em álcool ou drogas. Isso
aqui nós estamos trabalhando na faixa de
Ltn
12, 1,5 às 4,5 mg. Não pode fazer
liberação prolongada porque a gente quer
o bloqueio temporário para depois
bloquear. Nós queremos ação de oure. Por
que que vocês vão na academia? Os que
vão na academia, vocês vão pra academia
porque você quer ver o resultado depois
do exercício. Não é o exercício que
vocês querem. O exercício é estímulo. O
que vocês querem depois é o resultado do
exercício. Chama ormese, tá? Ovnese aqui
é a mesma cor, chama o você tomou o
negócio, bloqueou, o efeito você quer é
de desbloqueio, tá? Então, eh, não pode
ser liberação prolongada, os comprimidos
não podem ter celulose microcristalina
que se prefere tem que avisar a farmácia
colação. Não coloca a celulose
microcristalina porque atrapalha a
absorção e a biodisponibilidade.
Ah, existe o translito também, meu filho
do translâmico. Não é a forma mais
recomendada, mas só para você saber se
existe essa forma também.
combinações. Você pode combinar a com
quase tudo. Vocês viram aqui a aula de
tudo quantra coisa, que hipertermia,
ozônio, eh monte de fitoterapia, de
homeopatia, você pode combinar dele com
qualquer coisa, tá? Eh, o protocolo mais
conhecido o Berkson, que é o alfao,
que vocês podem também associar a
vitamina sem altas doses, tem efeitos de
topósito tumoral, vocês sabem disso, mas
vocês sabem, né? Deix que sabem. E a
melatonia de alta dose também é uma boa,
tá? Porque essa melatonia nessa dose
aqui, ela tem feito também a tumoral,
mas tem, sei lá, milhares de coisas. Tô
dando só alguns exemplos aqui, tá bom?
Dieta cetrogênica, né? O palestrante que
me antecedeu falou um pouquinho da dieta
cetogênica. Eu gosto muito da dietaflex,
né? Que é um tipo de dieta cetogênica
assim sensata, né?
Bem, existe um estudo grande na Brillage
Medical, esse BMC Medicine, que analisou
62 estudos randomis contra o trial e
estabeleceu que é muito seguro o uso do
LDM, tá? Então, risco de morte negativa,
ou seja, aquilo tem eh significância
estatística, mas teoricamente a pessoa
que dele morre menos, tá? Mas não tem
significância estatística, ou seja, é
muito seguro usar o RDM, tá? E você tem
aí uma experiência enorme mundial,
especialmente no Reino Unido e no
Brasil, mostrando que é muito seguro.
Exames. Eu vou passar rápido isso aqui
porque a maior parte da plateia acho que
não é da área de saúde, mas enfim, você
faz exames básicos de
tem que fazer no paciente onológico, né?
Função renal, função hepática. Eh, se
você tiver suspeita que o paciente pode
ser viciado em drogas e ele não vai te
contar que tá usando heroína, às vezes
ele tem que fazer um screen urinário. Se
você suspeita de uso de opio porque não
pode usar LDM junto com opio porque opio
ele vai brigar com o LDM, tá? Então não
tem como utilizar. Então, inclusive, se
a pessoa tiver tomando curador, se usar
o LM, vai bloquear o efeito analgésico
do opio
então monitoramento normal de paciente,
só que paciente que tem doença hepática
muito grave, isso tem que ser doença
hepática muito grave, você vai evitar de
usar o LDM e vai, em caso de pacientes
que tem doença hepática menos acentuada,
você vai fazer o monitoramento das
enzimas hepáticas.
Quais são os efeitos colaterais mais
comuns? Sonhos vivos. O pessoal tem um
sonho muito louco assim de LSD,
entendeu? Ficar vendo cores assim muito
intensas. Só ficar, tem gente, eu acha
que barato isso aí,
mas de vez em quando tem um pessoal aí
que tem uns pesadelos meio cautoso,
então não é comum, mas pode dar. Isso é
só no começo tratamento. Pode ter
pesadeiro, pode ter sonhos intensos.
Geralmente passa em duas semanas e tem
pessoas que táusa, dor de cabeça. E esse
flare, esse flare aqui, que isso aqui? É
tipo uma piora temporária dos sintomas
do câncer, tá? E geralmente quem tem
isso é bom sinal, né? Aqui o sistema
imune tá funcionando, tá? Então é um
sistema que parece muito com detox,
parece uma gripe que é de estado geral,
fatiga tal, que dura pouquinho, dura
duas, sean depois passa. Então é
possível também acontecer esse feito aí
colateral.
Outra indicação, não pode estar usando
morfina, fentanil, oxicodona, todas as
drogas ou piores.
Ausência de doença hepática muito
avançada também não pode ter
psensibilidade conhecida, né, a
autorexona.
E se tiver usando o opod e tiver como
tirar o opiod, tá? Tem que fazer um
shoutout, ou seja, tirar a droga aos
pouquinhos, tá? Se for pior de
importação, 7 dias. Se for pior de longa
duração, 10 a 14 dias. E se for fazer
cirurgia, tem que suspender o RDM 7 dias
antes da cirurgia, porque senão vai
ferir fentan. Que o anestesista faz
também, tá?
a exceção. Olha aqui, Dr. Luiz Sterno tá
aqui, os maiores homeopatas do Brasil,
deu uma aula fantástica agora a pouco.
Eu falei para ele: "Olha, isso aqui é
maior evidência de que eh homeopatia
funciona. 1 microgama de LDN tem ação
diferente de 1,5 e tem ação diferente de
50 mg."
Isso aqui existe uma uma ação de ultra
low, 1 a 10 mg que você pode usar junto
comodo, o contrário que eu falei, por
aqui aumenta a sensibilidade ao piodid,
tá vendo que a dose é tudo em medicina,
tudo. E isso aqui mostra dose super
baixa, funciona. Então isso é também a
prova escavar quemopatia. Não tem que
discutir maisopatia,
tem prova já funcional.
F as outras centenas de casos que o Dr.
Luiz tem muito mais capacidade para
falar do que eu muito bem.
Compatibilidade é compartido com
praticamente qualquer coisa, compatível
com eh imunoterapia, ajuda imunoterapia,
que esse aqui é a coisa mais moderna que
tem tratamento de câncer, imoterapia,
caro de doer, mas é o que tem mais
moderno,
ajuda a rádio, ajuda químio é compativo
e ajuda a esses tratamentos.
Estáuso legal é totalmente legal para
médicos prescreverem, tá? Porque é
registrada como um remédio tipo
antidepressivo, como se fosse a mesma
regulação do antidepressivo. Então, uso
prazer off label significa que é um uso
fora da bula. E qualquer médico
habilitado pode prescrever. O STJ
confirma a legalidade do off label, tá?
Só que você tem que usar a mesma
eh receita que se fosse para para passar
uma normal para pessoas que têm
independência.
Prescrição, receita branca carbonada
dupla.
Eh, é bom ter uma um consentimento
informado por escrito com uma
justificativa no prontuário utilizar
base científica que já tá documentário.
Então, nas farmácias de manipulação você
consegue, você não vai conseguir comprar
isso, como eu falei que na farmácia como
SUSA vai achar o révia, infelizmente o
SUS não cobre, mas já tem projeto
direito pro SUS cobrir.
Mas o custo não é muito alto. custo
geralmente entre 50 e R$ 150 por mês.
E esse aqui é o NCI, é o National
Instituto dos Estados Unidos, que fez a
análise do do caso do Dr. Berson. E eles
tiveram que admitir, esse negócio aqui
funciona, precisamos estudar isso aqui
com mais random mais control trial. Só
que não foi pra frente, não sei por.
Depois você me explica do também sei.
Ó, caso Dr. Bertson, passente 46 anos
com metá fígado, viveu 78 meses usando o
protocolo da alfa
RDN, retornou o trabalho.
Esse caso aqui, 39 meses sobrevida, era
esperado só três a 6 meses. O pet
negativado, ou seja, mostrou que a taça
sumiram. Qualidade de vida preservada.
Tá aqui o artigo, tá?
Ótimo. Outro artigo. Série
do MD Anderson. Taxa de resposta à 80%
de pessoas responderam a dor, dor
neuropática do câncer, tá? 71% de
melhora também. Dr. Biro 450 para 6, que
eu já comentei com vocês. Aí você vê
aqui a coisa é informação real, não é
dourar pílula. Ele teve 25% de redução
tumoral, aliás, 25% dos casos dele
tiveram resposta e os que tiveram a
resposta teve mais de 70% de resposta.
Aí eu falaria para vocês, eu usaria só o
LD passage com câncer? Nunca. O LD é uma
ferramenta maravilhosa, mas tem que ser
usado por toda essa arramentária que
vocês estão aprendendo aqui no
Congresso, certo? Mas aqui mostrando dá
os reais teve 25% de pacientes com
resposta e redução acima de 75%. E eu di
que é um dos principais centros
oncológicos do mundo, usa o
aí outros casos. Sistema ali na reles
avançado e os oncologistas mostravista
de anticancer research. 10 pacientes
metastáticos
resistentes quimioterapia, usou o
protocolo parecido com Berkson, como eu
falei depois, só que usou hidroxitato
também junto e o LDM, resultados, doença
estável ou lentamente progressiva na
maioria dos casos.
Esse também é um artigo do capo
investigations.
Duas crianças com tumor de
hepatoblastoma em tomor de fígado.
Primeiro caso, 10 anos sobre vida livre
de doença. Segundo caso, mais 5 anos
sobre vida de doença. Então tem esse
caso desse ano de 61 anos também com
uniforma de células de regressão da
máscara tumoral com o uso do LDM. Isso
que só usou LDM, tá? Tá? Se tivesse as
outras ferramentas que vocês aprenderam
aqui, tava muito melhor.
Isso aqui tá mostrando para vocês que o
LDN é totalmente seguro na gravidez, tá?
Esse aqui é um doutor obsteto ao lado da
Inglaterra, Dr. Fileri
e ele diz até que reduz aborto o RT.
E o Dr. Thomas Hilgers também dos
Estados Unidos reforçando essa
tranquilidade, essa segurança na US em
alta dosagem, tá? Mostrar esse na
gravidez.
Biomarcadores, a gente tem que
desenvolver mais ferramentas clínicas
para poder usar o LDM da melhor forma
possível. Por quê? Precisamos saber
quais são os pacientes que t mais
atividade desse sistema que eu expliquei
para vocês do OGF.
Então, a gente não tem essa ferramenta
clínica ainda por precisamos ter e
precisamos ter mais dados sobre o
sistema de defesa imune com essas
medidas aqui pra gente poder saber quem
é o paciente que vai gerenciar mais do
uso da ferramenta.
Então a gente precisa ter melhores
marcadores tumorais, melhores
ferramentas para ver a qualidade de
vida, maiores ferramentas para ver a
redução de norma oncológica e para ver a
estabilização radiológica do tumor.
Então quais são as limitações hoje do
LDN? Poucos estudos grandes implantam lá
esse control trail porque é muito caro,
porque ninguém vai colocar 10 milhões de
dólares no estudo de uma droga
peropatente. Esse são, infelizmente,
essa razão, estudos heteriogêneos.
combinações com outros agentes, tem que
ser feito mais estudos para haver essa
ação sinégérgica e tem os dados sobreviv
ainda limitados. Porém, essas são as
vantagens que eu já comentei em slide
anterior.
Isso aqui tá repetido.
Precisamos fazer mais estudos então com
protocolos utilizados, usar os bom
marcadores que não estão disponíveis
ainda, fazer estudos multicêntricos e
combinar com imunoterapia seria
excelente, que é muita, agora hoje tô
evoluindo muito.
E temos essas desvantagens aí que eu já
comentei também ao longo da
apresentação.
Esse aqui é um estudo que tá em
andamento, vai sair em setembro do ano
que vem, que é a associação do LDN, o
Progromol, Dr. Sér Felipe Júnior fala da
sala de crânomol,
mas espíromumap
e nivum. Que que é isso aqui? São dois
agentes imunoterápicos que aumentam a
atividades das células linfócos T.
Então, tá sendo feito esse estudo para
ver como é que o LDM tá ajudando esses
imunoterápicos a atuar, tá, no controle
desses cânceres aí de belão avançada.
Então isso aqui a gente tem várias
perspectivas de usar o inibidor de
checkpoint ou com terapia carte que são
as coisas mais avançadas que tem no
mundo oncologia hoje de imotapia
terapias extremamente caras,
extremamente avançadas que hoje se usa
para tentar aumentar a ontem aqui tava
aqui viu a Simon né, ela fez uma
imunoterapia dessa, não sei qual foi que
eu sei postar com ela. Eu queria tirar
foto com ela porque eu lembrava do
máico, mas eu não quer f
Então aí você tem aí essas combinações
promissoras e nós vamos cada vez avançar
mais com seleção genômica, marcadores
pessoais, né, através da
farmacogenômica, que é o estudo dos
genes que interagem as drogas, e
monitoramento tempo real.
Eh,
então a gente tem que ter esses esses
biomarcadores que eu comentei para saber
quais são os tumores que vão responder
melhor essa ação sobre AGF, GFR.
E a gente precisa ter eh uma seleção de
paciência de expectativa de vida mais
longa e função hepática preservada.
Bem, nós estamos chegando ao fim da
nossa apresentação. Quem quiser aprender
mais sobre tem esses livros referência
aqui. Esses livros aqui todos eu tenho,
tá? Então, de tudo vale a pena porque
isso aí para um monte de doença, né? Só
para câncer não ia dar tempo de falar
das outras doenças aqui. Eu acho que a
gente vai ter até um minutinho ou dois
para tirar dúvida se se a a direção
permitiu.
Esses são sites principais do mundo que
falam sobre LDM. L research high e o
lowvtrackson.org.
Aqui pessoal, QR code tem 100 e
39 estudos nesse TR, tá? É coisa
científica, né? Coisa tá nerd, não tem
mais o que fazer. Vai ficar esses
artigos aí.
Então tem aí o o QR.
Muito obrigado pela atenção de vocês.
[Aplausos]
Pode, pode deixar eles falar, eles
perguntarem
tá indicando aumentar para c
Sim, tem gente que usa para 6, que eu
postei no slide aí, tá? Esse 4,5 não é
sempre pedra não. Você pode dar uma eh
modificar isso aí.
É vivo, é vivo.
Olá, eu sou médica do L, também faz 4
anos pacientes. Inclusive a dosagem
seria 0,08 mg por t de peso, sendo dose
máxima até 4,5 como LDN, né? Mas eu usei
num paciente de 6 anos que tava com
retroitos ativa depois de 30 dias ele
fez uma nova colomoscopia e o médico
pediatra falou que estava treino de
diagnóstico. Na verdade, ele não tinha
mais nada. Sim, tem muita gente que
responde, eu não falei que não agora su
da aula, tá? Mas tem muita gente
responde ao uso do LDN para eh
inflamações intestinais, né, para cron,
retrul serativa, ele funciona bem e você
pode usar por peso também, tá? Até onde
eu sei não tem assim nenhuma evidência
se você usar essa progressão que eu
mostrei aqui ou usar do peso você fica
nessa faixa de 1,5 para 4,5 até 5 até se
tem até 6 km vai funcionar, tá
pessoal? Vou deixar vocês fazerem as
perguntas depois pra gente não estourar
muito tempo aqui, porque agora é o
horário do almoço.